okay good morning everyone my name is
Nick Hanna I'm the United States
Attorney for the Central District of
California here in Los Angeles with me
today his assistant Special Agent in
Charge mark Pearson from the Internal
Revenue Service Criminal Investigations
earlier today Michael avenatti a
nationally known lawyer was arrested in
New York City on two separate federal
cases one out of this district and one
out of New York information on the New
York case will be provided by the US
attorney in Manhattan I will discuss the
California case now the case was filed
in Santa Ana on Friday and was unfilled
today the case is the result of two
years of tax collection and
investigative efforts by the IRS the
federal criminal complaint charges mr.
avenatti with wire fraud and bank fraud
and contains a series of allegations
that paint an ugly picture of lawless
conduct and greed on his Twitter account
mr. abinanti describes himself as quote
attorney advocate fighter for good
unquote but the allegations in this case
describe something different a corrupt
lawyer who instead fights for his own
selfish interests by misappropriating
close to a million dollars that
rightfully belonged to one of his
clients the complaint also alleges that
mr. avenatti obtained bank loans worth
millions of dollars through fraud by
submitting phony personal income tax
returns and other false information to
the lending bank
according to the complaint the tax
returns were clearly false because mr.
avenatti
never filed federal income tax returns
for the years years in question and
never paid the federal income tax as
reflected on those false returns I'm
going to give you an overview of what
the two-count criminal complaint filed
in our district alleges
I do want to remind everyone that mr.
avenatti is presumed innocent unless and
until these allegations are proven
beyond a reasonable doubt in a court of
law in December 2017 mr. abinanti
negotiated a settlement for a client
that involved involved in a intellectual
property dispute under the settlement
1.6 million dollars was due to be paid
by January 10 2008 een at a meeting in
his law office in Newport Beach mr.
Alvin Adi gave the client a bogus
settlement agreement that instead listed
a later date March 10 2018 as the date
by which the payment was due the 1.6
million dollars was wired on January 5th
to an account controlled by mr. avenatti
mr. Homma not even used his clients
money to pay expenses for his own coffee
business global baristas LLC which did
business as Tully's coffee as well as to
pay his own personal expenses when the
fake March 10 deadline came and went the
client asked mr. avenatti where his
settlement money was mr. Robin adi never
told him
the money had arrived and to add insult
to injury between April and November of
2018
mr. avenatti quote/unquote advanced a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
his client so the client could meet his
own financial obligations while he
waited for the supposedly late
settlement money to arrive in essence it
appears mr. avenatti
loaned the clients own money to the
client money that mr. avenatti had
already secretly collected to this day
nearly fifteen months later mr. ah
vanadis client is still waiting for the
bulk of his settlement even even after
he hired another attorney who discovered
that mr. Robin adi had the funds all
along the facts alleged in the bank
fraud charge are as follows
beginning in 2014 mr. avenatti defrauded
the People's Bank a federally insured
institution in Mississippi by falsely
representing his and his businesses
income mr. abinanti did so by submitting
fictitious personal income tax returns
in a fraudulent law firm partnership tax
return to support his application for
three applications for three separate
loans totaling 4.1 million dollars to
obtain these loans mr. abinanti
submitted phony personal income tax
returns claiming to have earned a total
of 14 point 1 million dollars in
adjusted gross income for 2011 2012 and
2013 he claimed to have paid a total of
two point eight five million dollars in
estimated tax payments to the IRS in
2012 and 2013 in truth and in fact mr.
Alvin odd he never paid never filed
personal income tax returns for 2011
2012 or 2013 and he never paid federal
income tax during those years moreover
mr. abinanti still owe the IRS more than
eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in unpaid taxes interest and penalties
for the years 2009 and 2010 People's
Bank was ultimately repaid but only
after significant efforts and threats to
refer one loan to collections lawyers
have a sworn duty to obey the law and to
protect their clients our system of
justice depends on it mr. avenatti has
breached that duty and violated the
principles of honesty and fairness that
he claims to uphold if convicted of
these crimes mr. Alvin aadhi faces a
statutory maximum of 50 years in federal
prison
I want to thank hai RS Criminal
Investigations for their diligent work
on this case
work that began after an IMF IRS revenue
officer
criminal referral over a year ago I will
also note that the investigation is
continuing and IRS agents are executing
search warrants as we speak I also want
to thank our prosecutors on this case
assistant US Attorney's Julie and Andre
and Brett sagal for the many long hours
they have spent on this investigation we
expect mr. avenatti will make his
initial appearance before court in New
York later today on both cases we
further expect he will be ordered to
appear before a federal judge in Santa
Ana at a future date at this time I
would like to introduce IRS assistant
Special Agent in Charge mark Pearson
after which we'll take some questions
thank you good morning everybody my name
is Mark Pearson and I'm the assistant
special agent in charge of the Los
Angeles field office IRS Criminal
Investigations I'm here with US Attorney
Nick Anna to announce the filing of a
criminal complaint and arrest of Michael
Evan Eddie on charges of wire fraud and
bank fraud I wanted to start off by
stating that the current criminal
investigation involving mr. avenatti
began and continues to be an IRS tax
investigation the case was originally
averred referred by our collection
division based on irregularities they
were encountering in their attempts to
collect payroll taxes from mr. Evan
Eddie's businesses since the original
referral IRS Criminal Investigation
Division in partnership with the Los
Angeles United States Attorney's Office
has been conducting an extensive
financial investigation into these
business entities as well as mr. Evan
Eddie's personal financial transactions
based on the evidence uncovered by the
tax investigation IRS specially
expanded the original payroll tax
allegations to encompass additional
financial frauds which we believe have
been used to fuel an unrestrained and
lavish lifestyle by mr. Evan Eddy I wish
to emphasize this case originated from
our Civil Division pursuing the
resolution and collection of an
outstanding payroll tax debt as far back
as 2016 based on the anomalies found in
our collection officer by our collection
officers the matter was referred to the
Criminal Investigation Division around
September of 2017 by way of background
I'd like to paint you a picture
Michael Evan Eddy practiced law through
a vanetti and associates and Egon Evan
Eddie LLP in Newport Beach California
mr. Evan Eddie was the principal owner
and chief executive officer of global
baristas us LLC which operated Tully's
coffee shops in Washington state as well
as California it is alleged that between
2015 and 2017 tollis parent company
failed to file employment taxes tax
returns and pay approximately 3.2
million dollars in federal payroll taxes
similarly it's also alleged that e Eagan
and Eddie LLP failed to file payroll tax
returns and failed to file and failed to
pay I'm sorry approximately 2.4 million
dollars in payroll taxes this despite
mr. Evan Eddie's personal website
claiming that he has recovered over 1
billion dollars in verdicts and
settlements with regard to the criminal
referral of the employment tax case mr.
Evan Eddy is purported to have lied to
an IRS revenue officer and also change
bank account information as well as
instructed others to conceal and
relocate funds and effort to avoid and
defeat IRS tax liens and tax levies
constrained by these and other suspected
steps taken by Evan Eddie
to obstruct the IRS collection action
the revenue officer initiated the Frog
referral to our division in September of
2017 as this criminal case unfolded over
the course of the past 12 months we're
special agents found evidence of
financial fraud going well beyond the
original employment tax allegations with
respect to the wire fraud count from
about December of 2017 to the present
mr. Abernathy allegedly defrauded one of
the law firm's clients out of
approximately 1.6 million dollars which
was a settlement payment rather than
transfer his clients portion of the
settlement proceeds to his client mr. a
vanetti chose to use the entire 1.6
million dollars for his own purposes
it's difficult to imagine a greater
betrayal of trust than that between a
fiduciary and his client in regard to
the bank fraud count in 2014 Mike 11 at
his law practice and Coffee Company
obtained three separate loans totaling
over four million dollars
mr. Abernathy allegedly provided the
bank with false federal tax returns in
the attacks returns mr. Minetti
submitted he reported approximately four
to five million dollars in income for
each year and claimed with pay the IRS
2.8 million dollars in federal taxes in
reality mr. a vanetti never filed
personal income tax returns for those
years and has never made any tax
payments with relation to those years
today's announcement is about an
attorney who has failed to file personal
income tax returns charged with
embezzling clients money and defrauding
a bank all of these acts were taken to
support his lavish lifestyle which
included a venture into a car racing
company a lifestyle which is estimated
to exceed over $200,000 a month the
rental of a Newport Beach home at
$100,000 per month
and the ownership of a five million
dollar laguna beach home IRS Criminal
Investigation is a major contributor in
the effort to combat financial
institution fraud and the United States
Attorney's Office recognizes CI s--
investigative expertise in this complex
area finally imparting I'd like to say
to the professionals out there including
attorneys who create elaborate schemes
that have no other purpose than to
mislead others defraud the IRS their
clients and financial institutions they
run the very high risk of prosecution
these individuals may face severe
consequences including imprisonment and
substantial fines thank you okay we'll
take a few questions
[Music]
sure these were two separate
investigations but we have coordinated
the arrests so that there's one one
arrest on the two warrants and you would
we have a totally separate case separate
investigation we coordinated the arrest
for operational reasons but we obtained
our arrest warrant on Friday and we've
been building to that for quite some
time it was a lengthy investigation out
here we developed our case separately in
our case is completely separate has
nothing to do with the new york case we
just executed search warrants
simultaneously in new york when we had
him
I'm not going to speculate as to what
may or may not be in the case other than
what's already in the in the affidavit
in the lengthy affidavit there is some
reference to the bankruptcy proceeding
so I would just refer you to that you
know I'm not gonna speculate on on on
that other than I haven't seen a similar
case totally totally unrelated the the
the tax the tax efforts actually go back
to collection efforts actually go back
to 2015 with respect to the Egan and
avenatti law firm and then with respect
to the global baristas that cut the
coffee business that goes back to
September of 2016 so there have been
collection efforts going on for many
many years trying to collect taxes that
were not paid to separate cases our case
is completely separate than what's
happening in New York as I think was
mentioned we initiated a financial
investigation with respect to mr.
avenatti to look at various financial
dealings as you can see from the
affidavit a number of activities were
engaged in including the wire fraud with
respect to the clients money and
including the bank fraud there are other
allegations contained in the affidavit
but right now the only charges are the
wire fraud and the bank fraud but it was
a comprehensive look
I'm not going to speculate on that
completely untrue this investigation was
started in the ordinary course that came
up through the IRS based on collection
efforts of back taxes we investigated
this case in the ordinary course out
here it was driven by prosecutors in the
Central District of California working
with local agents has nothing to do with
anything political worth anything else
it's just the facts in this case speak
for themselves nothing to do with them
we were building to our charges all
along had no idea we have no idea when
the Muller report was going to come down
these things are two separate to
separate events documentary evidence I'm
not going to talk about that all I can
say is this is a very well investigated
manner investigated thoroughly by the
IRS and our assistant US Attorney's
we've documented a substantial amount of
evidence that's collected in the
affidavits that's been that have been
unsealed
I just command you to read those other
than that I'm not going to comment on
the strength of the evidence I'm not
sure about the specific timing I know
the arrest warrant was issued on Friday
I don't know about I don't know frankly
that the time of Windham Muller report
was was was was submitted
as indicated in the affidavit I think on
his personal income tax returns he'd
file for extensions with no tax due but
then never file actual returns or pay
any tax that that remains to be seen so
thank you very much everyone appreciate
your time thank you